- Маріуполь в небезпеці!
(хор голосів)
- Україна повинна безпосередньо розмовляти з "ДНР" і "ЛНР".
- Агресія 6 років часу проти українського народу
і дати їм ще статус - це неправильно.
Прифронтовий Маріуполь на перший погляд
сьогодні вже мало чим відрізняється
від інших українських міст. Про те, що війна
зовсім поруч, нагадують хіба що блокпости навколо
та понівечена під час зіткнень у 2014 році
будівля міської ради у самісінькому центрі міста.
А ще - проукраїнські активісти, які зібралися, щоб
напередодні зустрічі в "нормандському" форматі
записати відеозвернення до влади.
- Фейковий уряд ДНР перед "нормандською" зустріччю
малює кордони так званої "ДНР" у межах
Донецької і Луганської областей. Влада знову нічого не коментує.
Як я розумію, Маріуполь у небезпеці.
Місцеві активісти кажуть: їм бракує конкретики
щодо того, на які саме поступки Кремлю готова піти
влада заради миру. Бояться, що президент
Володимир Зеленський під час перемовин
перетне лінії, які для них є червоними.
- Якби проти Росії ввели належні санкції, вона б
уже давно відступила. Найстрашніше,
що може трапитися, - це реінтеграція Донбасу
в тому вигляді, як нині, без репарацій,
в обмін на визнання Криму російською територією.
- На окупованій території владу захопили терористи,
які вбивали наших солдатів, наших людей.
Якщо ми підемо на переговори з ними,
ми визнаємо їхню владу. Завтра вони прийдуть
до Верховної Ради і будуть тим гальмом, яке
не дасть нам далі рухатися в європейське майбутнє,
в Європейський Союз та НАТО.
Найпростіше було б відключити Росію
від міжнародної системи SWIFT.
Я вірю, що тоді Росія нас почує
й піде на домовленості, щоби в Україні був мир.
- Маріуполь у небезпеці!
(хор голосів)
Із Маріуполя їдемо в Мар’їнку -
одну з найгарячіших точок на лінії фронту
під Донецьком. Обстріли тут - звична річ.
Передові позиції військових,
звідки видно противника, у Мар’їнці -
просто на околиці міста. Повз зруйновані будівлі
колишньої школи-інтернату прямуємо до окопів.
Дорогою питаємо офіцера, який нас супроводжує,
як він бачить врегулювання конфлікту.
- Я думаю, домовлятися. Тільки політичним шляхом.
Жертви нам не потрібні. А вони будуть, якщо це буде
вирішуватися в подальшому військовим шляхом.
Усі кажуть, що розведення військ - це капітуляція.
А це не капітуляція, тому що противник теж відходить.
Капітуляція - це якщо ми відходимо і здаємо позиції.
Ми їх не здаємо нікому. Ми розводимо війська з обох сторін.
На крайньому посту нас зустрічає офіцер ЗСУ Тарас.
Каже, до позицій підконтрольних Росії сепаратистів
звідси - лише 300 метрів.
- Сильно голову не випихайте.
Бачите посадочку? Зліва вже противник.
Військові розповідають, що хоч активні бойові дії
зараз не ведуться, стріляють тут кожної ночі.
До того ж, бійці постійно напоготові
через диверсійно-розвідувальні групи противника.
Цікавимося в військових, чого вони очікують
від "нормандської" зустрічі.
- Дипломатично закінчити цю війну.
Узгодженням двох сторін припинити вогонь,
щоб люди перестали гинути.
- А з ким домовлятися потрібно, на вашу думку?
- То таке питання серйозне.
Насамперед потрібно домовлятися з Російською Федерацією.
Точно не з представниками "ДНР" і "ЛНР".
- А особливий статус для Донбасу ви підтримуєте?
- Особливий статус для Донбасу?
Агресія шість років часу проти українського народу
і дати їм ще статус - це теж, на мою думку, неправильно.
- Але ж вони цього вимагають.
- Мало що вони вимагають? Вони вже вимагали, щоб у 14-му році...
вони вже хотіли в Харкові й Києві ставити свої прапори.
До окупованого Донецька звідси лише 20 кілометрів.
Біля Мар’їнки розташовані ворота до так званої "ДНР" -
найбільший із п’яти пунктів пропуску на Донбасі.
Люди перетинають лінію зіткнення, щоб отримати
пенсію, купити дешевших харчів та ліків
на підконтрольній уряду території або відвідати
родичів, що опинилися по інший бік фронту.
У тонкощах міжнародного врегулювання конфлікту
тут не надто розбираються. Кажуть: аби не війна.
Взнаки дається і багаторічне перебування
в російському інформаційному просторі.
- Ще у 14-му році потрібно було домовлятися.
Ви ж бачите - Європа ж не йде бомбити Англію через Brexit?
Не іде. Домовляються, умовляють. А у нас відразу
війна почалася в 14-му році. Мирним шляхом треба,
дипломатичним.
- А з ким домовлятися? З Путіним?
- Ні, ну навіщо нам Путін? Це ж "ДНР" і "ЛНР"
владу цю київську не схвалили.
- У Зеленського є бажання домовитися.
Але яким буде тиск і з якого боку?
Не знаю, чи витримає він цей двобій.
- Я вважаю, що Україна має домовлятися напряму з "ДНР" та "ЛНР".
Я вважаю, що це одна країна і вирішувати проблеми
потрібно в своїй країні.
- Сподіваємося, щось вирішать, щоб був мир.
Щоб "ДНР", "ЛНР" - щоб усе це припинилося.
Щоб була єдина Україна.
- Донбас - це Україна?
- Ну так. Хоч нас, Донбас, і не любили, казали,
що ми москалі, "чортові москалі".
Теж образливо було.
Звичайно, Україна.
Ми ж з українськими паспортами їздимо.
Мені російський паспорт не потрібен.
Бачення того, як припинити війну на Донбасі,
у всіх різні. Єдині мешканці Донбасу хіба що в тому,
що хочуть миру. Вони сумніваються, чи вдасться
президенту Володимиру Зеленському його досягти.
Це можна зрозуміти, адже чітких сигналів від влади,
яким саме вона бачить вирішення конфлікту
й на які поступки Кремлю не піде в жодному разі,
справді бракує.